DAVID SHIROKOFF: Hi everyone.
I'm Dave.
Now today, I'd like
to tackle a problem
in orthogonal subspaces.
So the problem we'd like to
tackle: given a subspace S,
and suppose S is spanned by
two vectors, [1, 2, 2, 3]
and [1, 3, 3, 2].
We have a question here which
is to find a basis for S perp--
S perp is another subspace
which is orthogonal to S.
And then secondly, can every
vector in R^4 be uniquely
written in terms
of S and S perp.
So I'll let you think
about this for now,
and I'll come back in a minute.
Hi everyone.
Welcome back.
OK, so why don't we
tackle this problem?
OK, so first off,
what does it mean
for a vector to be in S perp?
Well, if I have a
vector x, and S perp,
and x is in S perp,
what this means is
x is going to be orthogonal
to every vector in S. Now
specifically, S is spanned
by these two vectors.
So it's sufficient that x be
perpendicular to the two basis
vectors in S.
So specifically, I can take
[1,  2, 2, 3] and dot it with x,
and it's going to be 0.
So I'm treating x as
a column vector here.
In addition, x must also be
orthogonal to [1, 3, 2, 2].
So any vector x
that's an S perp must
be orthogonal to both
of these vectors.
So what we can do
is we can write
this as a matrix equation.
And we do this by
combining these two vectors
as rows of the matrix.
So if we step back and take
a look at this equation,
we see that what
we're really asking
is to find all x that are in
the null space of this matrix.
So how do we find x in the
null space of a matrix?
Well what we can do is we
can row reduce this matrix
and try and find a basis
for the null space.
So I'm going to just
row reduce this matrix.
And notice that
by row reduction,
we don't actually change
the null space of a matrix.
So if I'm only interested
in the null space,
this system is going
to be equivalent
to-- I can keep the
top row the same.
And then just to
simplify our lives,
we can take the second
row and subtract
one copy of the first row.
Now, if I do that, I
obtain 0, 1, 1, -1.
Now, to parameterize the null
space, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to write
x out as components.
So if I write x with components
x_1, x_2, x_3 and x_4,
we see here that this
matrix has a rank of 2.
Now, we're looking at
vectors which live in R^4,
so we know that the null space
is going to have a dimension
which is 4 minus 2.
So that means there should be
two vectors in the null space
of this matrix.
To parameterize these
two-dimensional vectors, what
I'm going to do is I'm going
to let x_4 equal some constant,
and x_3 equal another constant.
So specifically, I'm going
to let x_4 equal b, and x_3
equal a.
Now what we do is we take a
look at these two equations,
and this bottom
equation will say
that x_2 is equal
to negative x_3 plus
x_4, which is going to equal
negative a-- x_4-- plus b.
And then the top equation says
that x_1 is equal to negative
2*x_2 minus 2*x_3 minus 3*x_4.
And if I substitute
in, x_2 is -a plus b.
x_3 is a.
And x_4 is b.
So when the dust
settles, the a's cancel
and I'm left with minus 5b.
So we can combine
everything together
and we end up obtaining [x_1,
x_2, x_3, x_4] equals -5b,
x_2 is minus a plus b,
x_3 is a, and x_4 is b.
And now what we can do is
we can take this vector
and we can decompose
it into pieces
which are a multiplied
by a vector,
and b multiplied by a vector.
So you'll note that this is
actually a times [0, -1, 1, 0]
plus b times [-5, 1, 0, 1].
OK?
So we have successfully
achieved a parameterization
of the null space of this
matrix as some constant a
times a vector
[0, -1, 1, 0] plus b
times a vector [-5, 1, 0, 1].
And now we claim that this
is the entire space, S perp.
So S perp is going to be spanned
by this vector and this vector.
Now notice how, if I were
to take either of these two
vectors in S and dot it with
any vector in the null space,
by construction, it
automatically vanishes.
So this concludes part one.
Now for part two.
Can every vector v in R^4 be
written uniquely in terms of S
and S perp?
The answer is yes.
So how do we see this?
Well, if I have a
vector v, what I can do
is I can try and write
it as some constant c_1
times the vector [1, 2, 2, 3]
plus c_2 times the vector [1,
3, 3, 2] plus the vector
c_3 [0,  -1, 1, 0] plus c4
[-5, 1, 0, 1].
OK?
So c_1 and c_2 are
multiplying the vectors in S,
and c_3 and c_4 are multiplying
the vectors in S perp.
So the question is,
given any v, can I
find constants c_1,
c_2, c_3, c_4, such
that this equation holds?
And the answer is yes.
Just to see why it's
yes, what we can do
is we can rewrite this
in matrix notation,
and there's kind
of a handy trick.
What I can do is I
can take these columns
and write them as
columns of the matrix.
And this whole
expression is actually
equivalent to this
matrix multiplied
by the constant,
c_1, c_2, c_3, c_4.
And on the right-hand
side, we have the vector v.
Now, by construction,
these vectors
are linearly independent.
And we know from linear
algebra that if we
have a matrix with linearly
independent columns,
the matrix is invertible.
What this means is, for any
v on the right-hand side,
we can invert this matrix and
obtain unique coefficients,
c_1, c_2, c_3, c_4.
This then gives us a
unique decomposition for v
in terms of a
piece which is in S
and a piece which is in S perp.
And in general this can be
done for any vector space.
Well I'd like to
conclude this problem now
and I hope you had a good time.